Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
« Lors d’un litige entre deux personnes
de statut civil coutumier kanak,
c’est le droit civil coutumier kanak
qui s’applique automatiquement. »
C’est du charabia ce que je viens
de vous dire, n’est-ce pas ?
Prenons un exemple concret
pour mieux comprendre.
Imaginez Marie et Joseph.
Vous allez comprendre pourquoi
j’ai choisi ces deux prénoms.
(Rires)
Après 30 ans de mariage et deux enfants,
ils décident de divorcer.
Le jour de leur mariage,
ils se sont dit oui trois fois de suite.
Un premier oui à l'église.
Un deuxième oui à la mairie.
Et un dernier oui dans la coutume.
Marie, elle est protestante
et Joseph, il est catholique,
et tous les deux sont
de statut civil coutumier kanak.
C’est-à-dire qu’ils ont
des droits et des devoirs
qui ne sont pas les mêmes
que les autres habitants non Kanak
de la Nouvelle-Calédonie.
Bon.
C’est un exemple parmi tant d’autres pour
illustrer un cas qui est réel et complexe,
en ce qui concerne le droit civil
coutumier kanak en Nouvelle-Calédonie,
Marie et Joseph vivent à la tribu.
Un jour, Marie,
qui ne supporte plus Joseph,
décide de partir, de quitter la maison
familiale et de refaire sa vie ailleurs,
tandis que Joseph reste à la maison
avec le fils aîné des enfants
et ne cesse de reprocher à Marie qu’aux
yeux de Dieu, ils sont toujours mariés.
Dans la coutume kanak,
il faut savoir que ce n’est
ni Marie ni Joseph
qui décide du comment
de leur divorce, non,
ce sont leurs clans respectifs
à tous les deux.
Un clan, c’est un ensemble de familles.
Chaque famille que compose
le clan a un chef de famille.
Le clan également.
Quand Marie et Joseph se sont mariés,
ils se sont dit oui,
pour le meilleur et le pire.
Le pire, c’est d’aller devant leur chef
de famille et leur chef de clan
pour annoncer qu’ils ne veulent plus
vivre ensemble sous le même toit,
que ça y est, c’est fini !
Parce que le jour où ils se sont dit oui,
trois fois de suite,
ce sont les familles et les clans
qui ont fait leur mariage.
Levez la main celles et ceux qui ont
déjà participé à un mariage coutumier.
Vous avez dû remarquer qu’il y a
du monde, beaucoup de monde
et beaucoup de nourriture aussi.
Ben oui, un mariage coutumier,
c’est aussi l’occasion de se retrouver
en famille proche et famille éloignée,
de resserrer les liens.
Si bien que c’est rare
de divorcer dans la coutume.
Et pourtant, ça existe.
Dans la coutume kanak,
on ne divorce pas « à la française »,
c’est-à-dire deux êtres se séparent
chacun de son côté et puis basta !
Non.
Dans la coutume, on parle plutôt
de « dissolution de mariage »
ou « séparation de corps »,
car les alliances qui ont été scellées
entre les clans ne peuvent être dissoutes,
encore moins quand il y a des enfants.
Car les enfants,
c’est le lien entre les clans.
Ce lien, fort, se traduit par l’esprit
de partage et de solidarité
entre les personnes issues des clans
lors de grands événements
et même au quotidien,
dans la vie de tous les jours.
La décision de divorcer revient donc
à chaque clan dont dépendent les époux.
C’est eux qui vont dire
ce qu’il faut faire et ne pas faire,
car dans la coutume, il y a des droits
et des devoirs à respecter.
Ça veut dire que c’est le clan
qui va guider la femme et l’homme
à la création d’une nouvelle
organisation sociale - dans la paix -
pour maintenir un équilibre
et ne pas détruire ce qui a été
construit et partagé en commun.
Trente ans de mariage, ce n’est pas rien.
En 1774, quand James Cook est arrivé
en Nouvelle-Calédonie,
il a trouvé des Kanak
sur une île paradisiaque,
qui vivaient de pêche,
de chasse, de cueillette,
qui faisaient des champs de taros,
des champs d’ignames.
Ils vivaient en harmonie avec la nature
et pratiquaient des échanges entre eux
qu’on nomme « coutume ».
Les groupes de personnes
qui vivaient au bord de la mer
échangeaient avec ceux
qui vivaient à la montagne
des poissons contre des notous.
D'ailleurs, dans la coutume kanak,
on trouve deux formes de troc.
La première,
c’est le troc à l’instant T.
« Je te donne une pierre de culture contre
des dents de cachalot, là, aujourd’hui. »
L’autre forme de troc,
celle que les Kanak utilisent
couramment et encore aujourd’hui,
c’est le troc rétrospectif.
« Je te donne des poissons aujourd’hui
parce que tu as faim.
Et demain, quand un champ d’ignames va
donner des tubercules, tu m’en donneras. »
Ça, c’est une définition
partielle du mot « coutume ».
Ce sont des usages coutumiers
qu’on pratiquait dans le temps
et qui sont toujours d’actualité.
Mais il existe aussi
plusieurs formes de coutumes,
aussi différentes les unes des autres.
Comme la coutume de naissance :
quand un enfant naît,
la famille se précipite chez le frère de
la maman pour annoncer la bonne nouvelle.
La coutume de bonjour :
quand on arrive dans un endroit
pour la première fois,
on s’annonce en se présentant :
« Qui je suis ?
D’où je suis et quel est
le motif de ma visite ? »
Mais aussi la coutume de mariage,
de deuil, d’adoption, de pardon
et même la coutume pour couper
un arbre qui gêne ma maison.
On demande l'autorisation de détruire
Mère Nature, cette mère nourricière.
C’est une forme de respect envers
l’environnement qui nous entoure,
le visible et l'invisible.
La coutume, elle est présente partout.
C'est quelque chose d'inné en soi.
Ce n'est pas du folklore.
Ce n'est pas un accessoire que l'on porte
et que l'on enlève quand ça nous arrange.
Non.
La coutume, elle fait partie intégrante
de la réalité du peuple kanak.
James Cook débarque donc
dans un monde aux coutumes très ancrées,
très puissantes et très structurantes.
Soixante-six ans après lui,
les Pères maristes arrivent
pour « évangéliser les sauvages »,
comme ils disaient
dans les livres d’histoire.
Pour « dompter les sauvages »,
les Maristes leur enseignent
le français, la langue de Molière,
par le biais de la Bible.
Les Kanak découvrent alors l’existence
d’un autre Dieu qui est invisible,
qui vit dans l’au-delà et non plus
avec eux et autour d’eux.
Ils découvrent également
une nouvelle langue,
une nouvelle manière
de s’habiller, de parler.
Ils apprennent à lire
et à écrire en français.
Imaginez le choc.
Mais les Kanak de l’époque,
plutôt dociles et conciliants,
approuvent ce changement sans rechigner.
Petit à petit, ils commencent
à délaisser leurs usages coutumiers
et à s’approprier cette nouvelle culture.
Les Maristes ont réussi
à les civiliser avec leur code.
Treize ans après les Maristes,
quand les autochtones ont bien assimilé
leur code, certains du moins,
Napoléon III dépossède l'archipel en 1853.
Dix ans après, il installe un bagne
et à partir de 1864
et jusqu’à aujourd’hui,
la Nouvelle-Calédonie devient
une colonie de peuplement.
Mais pour le peuple kanak,
l’assimilation n’a jamais été complète.
La coutume est restée vivante,
si vivante, qu’après bien
des détours et des souffrances,
les autorités ont décidé de faire
cohabiter deux droits civils.
Le droit civil romain
et le droit civil coutumier.
Le droit civil coutumier
est réservé aux Kanak
et le droit civil commun aux non Kanak.
La Nouvelle-Calédonie est
devenue avec les années
un territoire sur lequel vivent
des personnes dont l’origine et l’histoire
sont radicalement différentes.
Souvenez-vous de Marie et Joseph,
mon exemple du début.
Joseph, parce qu’il est croyant,
ne veut pas divorcer
car pour lui, le mariage, c’est sacré,
c’est Dieu, c’est catholique.
Et Marie, qui veut vraiment divorcer
malgré le principe coutumier religieux,
décide de porter son divorce devant le
tribunal de première instance de Nouméa
en formation coutumière.
Marie a le droit, c'est son droit.
Par ailleurs, la loi l’autorise
à être assistée au tribunal
par des assesseurs coutumiers.
Dans chaque litige concernant
le droit civil coutumier kanak,
les assesseurs présents sont
au nombre de deux par aire coutumière.
Ils sont d'origine kanak et travaillent
à côté du juge professionnel français.
Ils doivent pouvoir dire au juge français
comment on fait
dans chaque aire coutumière
comme le cas de ce divorce entre deux
personnes qui souhaitent se séparer.
Il existe huit aires coutumières, donc
huit variantes de pratiques coutumières.
Incroyable, non ?
Les assesseurs coutumiers,
ce sont des « juges coutumiers ».
Ils vont essayer de trouver
des solutions, des compromis,
pour ne pas faire de mal
aux enfants et aux parents.
Donc le juge professionnel
et les juges coutumiers
vont essayer de trouver
un équilibre entre Marie et Joseph.
A force de juger les litiges
entre Kanak au tribunal,
il y a eu l’apparition
de ce qu’on appelle une jurisprudence,
qui est une source de droit
et qui traduit les principes coutumiers de
la façon la plus noble et juste possible,
parfois différemment de ce que dirait
le droit civil commun par défaut
et qui fait que, maintenant, il existe
une loi écrite pour un litige coutumier,
notamment dans ce cas de divorce.
Le droit oral régi par la coutume
a donc été écrit,
donnant naissance
au droit civil coutumier kanak.
Aujourd’hui, il existe un droit coutumier,
mais que pour les affaires dites civiles -
naissances, mariages, décès, divorces,
successions,
adoptions,
autorité parentale,
assistance éducative, etc.
Il n'existe pas de droit pénal coutumier
pour les délits et les crimes.
La situation juridique
de la Nouvelle-Calédonie
est une véritable curiosité.
Déjà, il faut savoir que
le peuple kanak est mentionné
noir sur blanc dans l’accord de Nouméa,
lui-même inclus dans la constitution
de la Ve République française.
Aucun autre peuple sur le territoire
français n’y est cité,
à part bien sûr le peuple de France.
Mais le plus curieux, c’est l’existence
de cette coutume judiciaire,
un genre de cocktail
entre coutumes et lois écrites.
Bref, tout ça pour vous dire
qu’en Nouvelle-Calédonie,
une petite île perdue
dans l’océan Pacifique,
où vivent moins de 300 000 habitants
d’ethnies et de cultures différentes,
dans le droit,
on cultive la singularité
pour harmoniser nos couleurs.
Régulièrement, la coutume
s’écrit en jurisprudence,
lui donnant peut-être
encore plus d’existence.
Mais la coutume,
elle est vivante par essence.
Certains diront que l'écrire
en entier, c'est la tuer.
Mais l’écrire partiellement,
n’est-ce pas une solution
pour sauvegarder un patrimoine culturel
pour ensuite le léguer
aux générations futures ?
Je n'ai pas la réponse.
Je n'ai fait que me poser des questions.
Voilà.
C’est l’histoire d’un héritage ancestral
qui cohabite avec la modernité
dans mon pays.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)